[Music]
six hours KOCO celebrates those who have
passed and the lives they live through
Mexico's most popular holiday the
oscar-winning film has Disney
connections throughout that you don't
want to miss are you sure you've caught
them all watch this video until the end
to see what the shocking connection with
frozen is are you new to the things
welcome give us a like if you love Coco
as much as we do and hit the subscribe
button for more great videos like this
now on to 10 Disney connections in Coco
you should have noticed ratatouille and
wall-e dreams Coco has been touted as
the film that will bring back culture
and Pixar to the front lines Pixar and
Disney have created so many brilliant
films together it's hard to keep track
so they're helping us out by planting
seeds from other films and their newest
ventures the most recent film Coco has a
major shout-out to wall-e and
ratatouille that most people would have
missed but we got it here for you in
both these films the main characters see
their passions reflected in a TV set and
have a conscious heartfelt moment with
themselves their dreams are reflected
back to them and this happens to Miguel
in Cocoa as well in wall-e we see the
television reflection in his eyes as he
sees his dreams fully and ratatouille
our lovable rat Remy watched his star
chef on the screen as he dreams of being
one himself then in cocoa miguel watches
his dreams alive on screen as he dreams
of becoming a genius guitar player
discovering dreams is a typical theme in
disney films maybe this is because all
the filmmakers themselves once watched
films and saw their dreams of doing the
same in the future how beautiful now
they are passing their own message on to
young dreamers around the world
Nalla Theory Pixar's capabilities are
well known they certainly got that right
however we have an interesting theory on
fajita Pepita is an alibi he which is
the Mexican paper mache or wood
figurines that represents mythical
animal mashups they are not actually
associated with the famous holiday that
takes place on October 31st when the
Pixar team's research trips to Mexico
they loved the figurine so much they
wanted to bring them into the film we
think fixed are subtly incorporated nala
from the famous Disney film The Lion
King into their masterpiece of Coco
through
when the animators created the animals
it seems they use parts of Nala
especially her face they obviously
brought in their own craftsmanship and
expertise that represented Mexican
culture and adjusted the design based on
what they wanted the pizza was created
with an amalgamation of different
animals including eagle wings Alliance
body a lizard tail and the back feet of
a chicken then covered in beautiful
colors her glows lights up those around
her in the film and her loving persona
but don't you think pepitas welcoming
face is eerily similar to knotless from
The Lion King
looks pretty spot-on to us what do you
think about this Disney connection
theory linking Pepita and Nala
perhaps it's Nala in the afterlife The
Incredibles 2 ticks are always leaves
Easter eggs in their films for their
next upcoming project this time around
however it seems they may have been
slightly unsure which film was being
released first there is one hint what
has now been confirmed as their next
feature The Incredibles 2 it almost
seems like maybe that was a last-minute
addition to the film as it was one
simple small hint that many may not have
noticed if you watch Miguel and Hector
as they make their way to Mexico's
biggest holiday talent show there is an
Incredibles poster on the alley wall a
subtle nod to the new film the reason
why it's known that this is a
last-minute addition is that Toy Story 4
was originally slated to be their next
foam however Disney and Pixar decided
that The Incredibles 2 will be their
next massive release when they released
Koko Disney also released the trailer to
The Incredibles 2 getting us all way too
excited for the thrilling sequel
monsters Inc in 2001 Disney release the
film that influenced every child's fear
of monsters yep that's right
the infamous Monsters Inc making
monsters less scary and more well
approachable if that's a thing with
monsters Coco has done the exact same
thing with the deceased and skeletons
taking a loved traditional Mexican
holiday that may seem scary to other
cultures and making it approachable fun
and overall exhilarating in America we
celebrate Halloween is a scary thing on
October 31st while in Mexico they are
celebrating the lives lived we like
where their minds are at in cocoa there
is an acknowledgment to monsters Inc in
the form of Kenyatta's want to know
where to look as Miguel makes his way
through the town
heading to the plaza he passes by
multiple people and stalls this one is
an easy one to spot in a bundle of
piñatas amongst them are Sully and Mike
Wazowski in addition to some Woody and
Buzz Lightyear pinatas the director of
Coco also directed Monsters Inc among
many other Pixar and Disney films the
secretly hidden shoutouts to his
previous films are all over Coco which
we are having a blast finding but as
much as we like candy we're not sure we
want to beat Sully or Mike Wazowski up
luxo jr. do you guys know who luxo jr.
is well luxo jr. is the name of Pixar's
first short animated film from 1986 it
is a story revolving around two lamps
one larger lamp watching a younger lamp
play with the iconic bouncy ball you may
remember it from seeing the short at the
theater before one of the Pixar films
began to play the short was directed by
John Lasseter who is one of the founders
of Pixar and has written multiple Disney
and Pixar films including Toy Story and
cars so how does this short film that
could be responsible for starting
Pixar's massive success connect to Coco
well if you watch closely you can spot
the famous red and yellow ball from luxo
jr. in the scene roomie Galan Hector go
to the sunrise concert rehearsal area
Dante the dog gets in a scuffle with a
monkey in the background you gotta be
quick to spot the luxo ball sitting on
the desk so basically that's one nod in
plain sight to the studio's creation
another fun fact if you're willing to
try the luxo ball can be seen in almost
every Pixar Disney film so get spying
and comment below if you found it Toy
Story anyone who loves Pixar is likely
to love Toy Story we're happy to say
that we're obsessed with the Toy Story
films and couldn't wait to discover all
the clues in Coco 2 the upcoming Toy
Story 4 which was originally going to
follow Coco their slate has changed and
now The Incredibles 2 will be coming out
before the 4th Toy Story
there are many shout outs to the Disney
films the first being the Pizza Planet
truck which we saw in the original Toy
Story film the truck 2 zooms by Miguel's
house playing loud music the sign on the
roof has been adjusted to Pizza Planet
ah another reference to the excessively
successful film is a little bit more
subtle at the beginning of the film when
Miguel dashes towards the center he
passes through
streets you can see a bundle empanada
strung up for sell they are in the shape
of Woody and Buzz Lightyear but wait we
don't want anyone beating candy out of
our favorite character Dewey seeing as
the director Leon Chris worked on the
Toy Story films in multiple ways such as
co-director and story creation seems
right he's given a shout out to his
beloved past work did you find any other
Toy Story connections if so you've got
one quick I John Ratzenberger this actor
is known as Pixar and Disney's good luck
charm
he has voice roles in every single Pixar
film and multiple Disney projects John
Ratzenberger is best known for the
voiceover of Mac in all the cars films
the animation mongrel hired John again
for Coco
however this may be the role you did
miss in Coco his character name is Juan
orthodontia who barely even speaks the
name orthodontia which clearly suggests
his character must have something to do
with teeth gets crossed over on Mexico's
famous holiday after being remembered by
his dentist John made his name famous
back in the 80s when he brought cliff
Clavin to life on the famous TV series
Cheers
John played ham and Toy Story as well as
Mustapha in ratatouille as for Disney
John did the voiceover on a series of
video games that Disney came out with
John must be pretty happy that his work
is very secure even in the Mexican
culture film Coco the studio had to have
him back the film won two Oscars and we
wonder if John really is their good-luck
charm
guess we'll only find out when he isn't
in one of the films sits goal yep we got
another Toy Story acknowledgement for
you to the evil Sid that scared us all
as children with his violence and
volatility to toys the director of Coco
also directed Toy Story 3 and melded his
passion for the two films together the
main image of the film which was even
sold on t-shirts prior to Coco's release
is from the original Toy Story film Sid
wears a black shirt with a white skull
on it which became an iconic image
throughout the films being identified as
the bad guy this goal is now the main
image of Coco but reimagined in a bright
and colorful way another nod to the
torturous Sid is at the talent show in
the land of the deceased where a DJ
wears the exact shirt Sid wore during
his lackluster performance we
like the skeletal DJ may even be saying
that stood past and he's now a seemingly
sad DJ in this alternate land the theme
of Toy Story and cocoa is prevalent and
we've had a blast finding all the
references but the skull from SIDS shirt
may be the best one
as it fits perfectly in with Mexico's
most popular holiday Pixar does it again
Finding Nemo Coco was crafted
meticulously for years with proper
research and even more work put into
making sure Mexican culture was
represented accurately Disney and Pixar
wanted Mexicans to feel proud of the
film they created so after all that work
we understand why the creators wanted to
make some shoutouts to the work they're
proud of Finding Nemo one of the
studio's most successful films was
hinted at in Cocoa more than once as
Miguel is heading to the plaza he passes
a stand with toys displayed on it one of
them is a tiny figurine of our lovable
clownfish Nemo
the toys are Albury keys which are
Mexican folk art sculptures in Coco they
are the spirit guides in this colorful
land that's opposite to the living the
filmmakers have remained true to the
Mexican culture so does that mean we
influence Mexico with the Pixar and
Disney exciting and emotion provoking
films frozen let it go was one of the
biggest Disney musical hits in the last
decade taking home numerous awards and
even becoming popular as a solo track
the married songwriter collaborators who
compose that oscar-winning track is
couple Robert Lopez and Kristen
anderson-lopez the couple met with Coco
director Lee Unkrich in 2011 to discuss
writing a song for the film for years
they thought about the music and came up
with a film's anthem song remember me
which won them their second Oscar at the
2018 Academy Awards the couple's
inspiration strikes at the oddest times
years ago on the F train as Kristen was
commuting from Brooklyn to Manhattan
she wrote the lyrics to remember me just
after her husband Robert cracked the
melody that morning in his boxers in an
interview with Vanity Fair the couple
explained that they've really connected
with Hector Riviera's character he wrote
a love song about his love for his
daughter this was very close to their
hearts as they have two daughters
themselves and the two girls are their
first critics the couple always plays
their music first for their daughters
and if
like it they know it's good well we
couldn't agree more this duo is
unstoppable whether with Disney or Pixar
their music rings true in the hearts of
their audiences remember me will be
played for years to come
what did you think was the most exciting
connection let us know in the comments
below thanks for watching 10 Disney
connections in cocoa you should have
noticed see you next time
[Music]